oh i would love that
one division finale week is upon us
people so
our week continues by covering people's
theories and such to see what comes true
because that's part of the fun of the
game for us
and a lot of marvel fans as well so
today we will continue with
warren from cosmic wonder my friend and
future housemate one division episode
nine doctor strange scarlet witch chaos
magic he's been killing it on his
channel if you guys want more marvel
content follow him he mainly does marvel
he's constantly up to date with all the
latest
jazz out there and he gives me the heads
up on things he's a great guy
i love him i love you warren loves you
more than me
yes what's going on everybody it's
warren welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and yesterday we got
one division episode eight only one more
one of the videos came out a few days
ago this series ends and although
they've revealed a lot about wanda
vision in the past couple of episodes
there's still a lot that needs to happen
and right now with a combination of
theories leaks and simple predictions we
could probably narrow down
a few things that have to happen in one
division
nine the grand finale but if you have
not seen one division episode eight or
any of the episodes before it
this is your spoiler warning you should
probably click away now unless you don't
care and of course if you're new and you
love marvel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
so the first thing that we need to
address is the fact that white vision
ghost division gray vision whatever you
want to call him the version from the
west coast avengers vision
is now in one division and it's very
clear now that
the vision that wanda created her vision
is going to have to fight
hayward's vision so we're going to have
paul bettany acting
with himself in an episode so we have to
talk about that secret cameo that paul
bettany was teasing
could this actually be himself this
actor that he said he's
always wanted to work with that he's had
really good chemistry with that he
worked
very well with on the set could it
actually just be himself could he be
trolling us
there you know what's funny is like i
made a joke ro when the episode was done
about that yeah and i love how some
people are actually going out there
did did he really mean himself guys come
on no way
that's that's just silly to me but it's
true that's
hilarious that's a hilario i love a good
troll
that'd be hilarious could he be trolling
us there is a chance and if that's the
case i'm going to be pretty upset but
also at the same time
pretty funny move by paul however let's
not forget that elizabeth olsen did
confirm that there is going to be
indeed a huge cameo from somebody and we
haven't seen
the engineer yet so a big cameo is going
to be coming and a final
huge fight is going to be coming of
course as well
and one thing that's going to happen
that seems to be kind of obvious at this
point is that
wanda is going to have to kill vision
all over again
hayward's new version of vision is
essentially ultron and
ultron is pretty much now a puppet for
hayward it's almost like he has a remote
control
vision to kind of do whatever he wants
and right now he hates
wanda he even lied about her breaking
into the facility to kidnap vision's
body which of course we found out in the
last episode
is absolutely not true wanda was
actually pretty silly about the whole
entire thing
she went in said goodbye to vision and
left without harming anybody
but hayward being the director of sword
the sentient
weapon observation response division
kept his body and created from him a
sentient
weapon and there's no doubt that he is
going to send this weapon this version
of vision
after wanda who is responsible for
taking over these people
and the city of west view now wanda is
going to have her family with her but
just judging by the way that
everything's been happening for wanda
all of the trauma that she's had to face
during her life
it's most likely going to be her that's
going to have to kill this version of
vision
kind of reliving her pain all over again
and then of course there's a possibility
that the actual vision that wanda
created will not make it
out of the reality this vision won't
survive either we have seen him outside
of the hex and it doesn't seem like he
is allowed to leave and it seems like if
he stays outside of the hex he will in
fact die
and i definitely think it's safe to
assume that one division is going to end
with the hex disappearing
so it's not only looking like one vision
is going to die but
both visions are going to die but you
see this is what's fun about this
is that we just watched a new rock stars
video where the main theory
they'd be slapping them together right
you know that means they're putting the
soul back in the body
yeah and then this one uh from warren is
talking about how
they'll be uh having to fight each other
or wando will most likely have to
live her trauma again after kill
envision
watching vision die by uh the hands of
thanos
and then having to kill this new vision
i could see a scenario where
wanda does have to take out the sentient
weapon vision the white vision
i think it would be more climactic if it
was
scarlet witch's vision having to take on
the white vision
yeah that's the face that's the one i
personally love yeah
cause there was an episode seven when
he's talking with darcy in the
in the funnel cake truck or something
about what is my identity i was
programming
from ultron and then for him to come
face to face with
the thing that he was ultimately
designed to be the white vision
yeah i think that would just make for a
better arc for vision overall oh yeah
and something based off of the exact
thing he didn't want
to have happen you know coming to life
right now for his eyes you know
we'll see yes i mean take that three
tonight
obviously further in that's why i love
these theories because they're like
which one's gonna be but the same can't
be said
for wanda's children she didn't actually
create them with her magic
well sort of but she actually birthed
them she actually became pregnant and
had her kids
and of course we know that the young
avengers are coming so it would make
sense that billy and tommy or
wiccan and speed would be a part of the
young avengers therefore it would make
sense that they would survive
and again wanna didn't simply create
them like she did vision she actually
had them
so they could probably survive outside
of the heck since they are actually
real humans or they could technically be
mutants and speaking of mutants we still
have evan peters's fox version of
silver yes what is this
the last time that we saw him was
episode seven in the post-credits scene
where he had
monica rambo now of course i got the
harkness revealed that she was
possessing
this person in order to obtain
information from wanda to figure out how
she created everything
how she cast so many spells at once and
had
thousands of people under control so
he's an actual person he isn't a
creation of her
and since we're about to dive into the
multiverse of madness he very well could
be the quicksilver from the fox universe
and vision has the power to awaken him
he has the power to take him
out of agatha's spell and if he does so
that would probably mean that since
agatha is the one that hexed him he
would be fighting alongside
wanda vision and of course her twins and
that brings us
oh i would love that and if they
actually
did some type of tribute to the x-men
movies with you know
like the evan peters famous one of those
slow motions
yeah oh that would be so cool i would
love that yes i would love to see pietro
actually team up
especially after all of the like he's
not your uncle like to to have some
redemption there would be sweet yeah
because i'm kind of messed up you just
take quick silver the best part of the
x-men movies that's a blade
you throw them over here and that brings
us to the final
battle there are going to be a lot of
people involved in this battle
now before the post-credits scene of one
division episode 8
we assumed that it was going to be wanda
vision her twin boys wiccan and speed
monica rambo with her new powers making
her photon or
spectrum an awakened quicksilver we're
gonna get
such an epic battle i forgot about that
but now we know that hayward's vision is
going to be joining the picture as well
and we know that this vision is going to
go after wanda but
is this vision also going to go after
agatha or
is agatha going to have some sort of an
ally in this battle
vision vs vision seems indefinite at
this point in time so maybe when the two
visions are fighting agatha will be
fighting
wanda her twins quicksilver and monica
at the same time
however i do have a theory about agatha
harkness that could take us in a
different direction
perhaps she's not actually bad in one
division she doesn't really seem to be
doing everything that she's doing
because she's evil
she actually seems to be doing
everything because she's scared
now when we had agatha's little theme
song stating that she was behind
everything she wasn't actually
responsible for creating this reality
and controlling the people
yes she did influence some events that
had happened but she didn't start it all
and the reason that she did
influence some events that happened is
because she wanted to figure out how
wanda started it all agatha came to west
view because she
sensed the spells that wanda cast and
she wanted to know who cast these spells
who was responsible for
all of this power for controlling all
these people
look all right i'm gonna interrupt this
right away
there's one thing my mind goes to when
saying that she's maybe not bad it's the
final moment of the agatha all along
song where she looks at the camera
and says i and i killed sparky and
laughs
maniacally that's a fair point that's a
villain
okay that's just that's all i'm gonna
say
scared agatha because she knew what this
was she knew that it was an extremely
powerful being
she came to west view realized it was
wanda who did everything but wanted to
know how she did it she wanted to know
how she was this powerful and then in
the last episode of one division
she finally realized how she did it she
realized that wanda is a scarlet
witch and she has chaos magic and this
scares agatha so agatha seems to be
approaching wanda and everything that
has happened not from
an evil side but a curious side which
then
eventually led into a scared side so it
could be possible that agatha
isn't actually bad she just fears wanda
for what she is
a scarlet witch so perhaps if she finds
out that wanda can indeed be good
kind of like agatha's mother told her
during the salem witch trials
perhaps agatha could actually be friends
with wanda and let her live
especially if she has some type of
mentor or coach which is where the next
theory comes in
that doctor strange is going to show up
at the end of one division
paul bettany said that the final battle
of one division is going to have
more cgi than avengers in game had and
if you can
see there's a lot of [ __ ] which is going
to fight each other and
junior who will most likely be involved
somewhat in the fight we can assume
that there's going to be a lot of magic
involved in this final fight which would
require that cgi
and there's no way a huge final magical
battle is going to go down without
doctor strange sensing this agatha
darkness picked up on the magic that was
going on
okay but i'm just curious how he would
show up because
it might be a little bit of a repeat
beat if it's like
sling rings again on your left yeah yeah
yeah
falcon and when your soldiers show up
everyone
and toby mcguire part of me wonders if
maybe that means there will be just like
tons and tons of reality warping or
stuff like that because i think of end
game and i'm like well
okay you kind of for the climactic
battle have one
setting maybe this will be a reality
warped like everything shifting and
changing yeah
kind of like an extreme version of what
was happening in episode seven when
wanda was starting to break and maybe
it'll go even more surreal like some of
those you know nightmarish
hallucinations
spider-man and other movies doctor
strange i don't think it means as many
quantity of characters
yeah maybe i think a lot of us go to
yeah
because you wouldn't need to cg all of
the characters
agatha harkness picked up on the magic
that was going on in west view and
granted she is a lot older than doctor
strange is and a lot more experienced we
can still assume that doctor strange
will eventually
pick up on the magic that is happening
after all it is doctor strange's
responsibility to protect
this reality that the main mcu is in he
stated that in avengers infinity war
when he told tony stark which brings us
to the final theory that at the end of
one division
wanda will go with doctor strange now
this is in fact
confirmed the president of marvel
studios has already told us that one
division will tie directly into doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
and
wanda is going to be one of the main
characters after magneto and professor x
show
right here that's right dr strange got
to get her back his job was
protecting the reality and it's now
revealed that wanda has reality warping
powers chaos magic and this is not good
for doctor strange who tries to protect
reality
so this has to be the key of why doctor
strange actually takes wanda under
his wing he you know it would be cool if
mordo shows up
oh mordo shows up
after the events of doctor strange the
post credits scene yeah
how this exact line was too much too
many sorcerers or something like that
yeah yeah
if he showed up oh my goodness whatever
that's
crazy yeah it's almost if if we're
getting the cadence right that's almost
like no more mutants
actually in some ways that would make
more sense it wouldn't be like a luke
skywalker level cameo but it would be a
it wouldn't make sense and then it's
like doctor strange isn't here
necessarily to like
recruit or wrangle one it's like no no
no come back from the dark side
he needs her to learn how to control
this reality warping magic so it doesn't
actually affect their reality
he can't have wanda being a threat to
the universe so he takes her
under his wing however i still think
that her chaos magic comes from the
elder
demon god c'thun i believe that just
like in the comics he
marked her therefore giving her part of
his chaos magic
and i think that this could be the main
villain of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
now just to address one final thing that
i've been hearing a lot of theories
about
all you theorists keep switching around
who the big baddie is
for memphis
reaper god the theory that hayward
is actually ultron it is a great theory
however i don't believe this to be true
i think he's just a jerk
i think he's afraid of super powered
individuals which is why he wanted to
use
vision's body to essentially create an
ultron that he can control but i do not
think that he himself is ultron but
we'll find out in less than a week now
in the meantime let me know what you
think about all these theories
in the comments down below and let me
know what you think is going to happen
in the final episode of wanda vision
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest one
division news give the video a like and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
i think the one thing all the theorists
seem to be agreeing on because
everyone's like
what if hayward's this what if he were
this and every youtuber is like nah he's
just a dick it's just a government dick
it's just a dick one thing
that um we got some crap on about how
we were all for the the plausibility of
that wanda does indeed have mutant dna
based off the fact of her powers from
birth a lot of people were like no she
has magic she's a witch it's not mutant
but i'm like how then could pietro
survive the hydra test how could he then
develop super speed yeah i mean if
everyone else
died and he's not a witch he's not
doesn't have magic
unless that's what they're going to say
for him but i don't think they're going
to say that for him
so i think like the witch thing maybe
they actually thought like oh the the
witch stuff is actually mutant dna the
way how we have like
concluded awful things about people
before
that was a really fun one a lot of good
information there warned proud of all
these videos you've been doing i love
i've been enjoying your theories in
braille i
listen and watch a lot of them on my own
time but it's i was like it's been a
while man it's a finale week we got to
cover at least one cosmic wonder video
guys subscribe to cause wonder if you
haven't done so already subscribe to us
click that notification bell get
notified when a reaction for one
division finale is
up hit that like button last but not
least
lance door where the hell are you i
haven't heard from you in so long it's
hard to get a vision
of you no
no why not yeah we've got nothing to
work with
considering the fact that lance hasn't
been talking to us what i will say is
this
even though you haven't been talking to
us glad you've kept that pledge alive
that's right it's like talking
it's more effective i mean i might say
all these things
about like where have you been i want to
talk with you but hey
as long as your pledge is still active
do we really need to talk
we don't need to talk we don't need to
discuss this again unless i see you
lower that pledge and i'm like
whoa whoa hey everybody how you doing is
everybody catch up with you
you need me to you know do anything you
need to talk you okay it's all right you
won't see this so i could say whatever i
want
your daughter's really my daughter